llegando al final de estos juegos a esta
hora concluye la penúltima jornada en la
que se entregan cincuenta y seis preseas
doradas y que ya tiene a colombia como
la delegación campeona con más de 150
metales dorados 11 medallas de oro
entregado y el atletismo y nuestro
enviado especial luis méndez ha estado
cubriendo esta jornada del deporte rey
en este tipo de justas hola luis
saludos guantes escucho muy bien y sobre
el atletismo te debo decir que en esta
ocasión en esas once preseas doradas
repartieron entre diversos países
comenzando por la prueba de lanzamiento
de disco que en esta ocasión ganó la
chilena karen gallardo esta atleta
nacida en valdivia de 38 años consiguió
su mejor lanzamiento en 59 38
centímetros no estuvo conforme con la
marca que le dio la medalla de oro pues
recientemente en su país natal había
participado en una competencia donde
rozó los 60 metros en su lanzamiento
aquel entonces fueron 59 99 mientras
tanto en el de 400 metros vallas
femeninos la representación de panamá se
alzó con los máximos honores a través de
jana food group esta atleta ha nacido en
santa mónica de estados unidos y que ha
representado a la nación istmeña en dos
ocasiones en los campeonatos mundiales
de atletismo 2017 2019 y lo hará
próximamente en oregón dentro de
se quedó con el mejor registro de esta
prueba para colgarse la medalla de oro y
espera seguir trabajando en texas donde
reside para lograr estar en las finales
de los campeonatos mundiales de
atletismo en cuanto a esta misma prueba
pero en la rama masculina la medalla
dorada recayó en el atleta dominicano o
under santos wander venía de un regreso
luego de estar cerca de tres años fuera
de la actividad del atletismo muchas
lesiones algunas complicaciones había
presentado este atleta previo a su
participación en los juegos bolivarianos
y aunque ganó la prueba no se sintió
satisfecho con la meta con la marca
registrada el día de hoy por escuchemos
qué fue lo que nos dijo al concluir la
prueba
comienza este año mientras el pasado que
fue el que me llevó a antes hacer
finalizó mundial
y ya en un año ya casi estoy volviendo a
mi forma óptima que tenía hace tres años
y ahora estoy volviendo volviendo y eso
lo que me ha llevado a correr
intermitentemente que corro 49 que
vuelve y 450 que 49 50 y me ha tenido
así la falta de confianza de eso
en otra prueba de atletismo las 5000
metros femeninos fue para la
representante de chile- josefa quesada
que se quedó con el primer lugar en
cuanto al tenis de campo dos medallas se
entregaron el día de hoy colombia cargó
con los máximos honores en el doble
femenino al tiempo que ecuador hizo lo
propio en el dobles mixto el baloncesto
3 por 13 fue para venezuela que venció
ecuador en tiempo extra